這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
Crusoe 退掉了 Boom Supersonic
超過12.5億美元的大單
一共29台發電渦輪機
Crusoe 可是 Boom 最關鍵的客戶
這筆單為什麼這麼要緊？
Boom 的算盤是先賣地上發電機
再用營收和獲利造天上飛機
也就是 Overture 超音速客機
這筆訂單未來若帶來持續營收與獲利
本來就是要養超音速客機的
回頭看 Boom 的飛機：2025年1月
XB-1 驗證機突破音障，最高1.05馬赫
可是 XB-1 用的是3具現成的 GE 引擎
不是自己造的
那 Boom 自己的引擎呢？
原本共同研究推進系統的 Rolls-Royce
在2022年退出
Boom 後來改為主導開發 Symphony
客機跟引擎兩條線都得繼續推
兩樣都花大錢，錢從哪來？
執行長 Blake Scholl 自述
他曾傳訊問早期投資人 Sam Altman
電力是不是 AI 的主要限制
Altman 回答是
既然缺電
Boom 就以同一套引擎核心為基礎
做成地面發電用的天然氣渦輪機
Superpower
單機輸出42 MW
跟 Symphony 約8成硬體共用
賣給 AI 資料中心
時間回到2025年12月
Boom 拿下 Crusoe 這張大單
2026年2月又先訂了31具發電機
現在大單沒了，這批發電機要去哪
還沒有公開答案
話說回來，燃氣發電設備是真的缺
大廠 GE Vernova 的訂單和產能預留
從2025年底的83 GW
漲到2026年第二季的116 GW
且已開始接受2031年交付時段的預留
可是反差在這：Crusoe 沒放棄渦輪機
早就向 GE Vernova 訂了接近1 GW
它不是不懂天然氣發電
也不是突然不要電，偏偏退了 Boom
那會不會是 Crusoe 缺錢？
9月17日
Crusoe 才宣布 F 輪完成初次交割
整輪預計規模39億美元8天後
Scholl 就在 X 上宣布雙方不再合作推出
Superpower
不缺錢，那為什麼退？
雙方各說各話
TechCrunch 報導
Scholl 貼文裡原本寫的原因被刪了
Crusoe 發言人則向 TechCrunch 表示
能源計畫沒變，仍會用渦輪機
只是不是 Boom 的
真正原因都沒公開
比起分手原因，工程進度更敏感
9月初發布的工廠參訪影片顯示
首顆引擎核心還在最後組裝後面要點火、
連接發電機、跑滿載耐久測試
離整機測試還有一段路
組裝都還沒完成
Boom 仍然喊出2027年交付約250 MW
2028年拉到1 GW
可是新客戶是誰，Boom 一個都沒公布
所以下一關就是點火：
首顆核心能不能在2026年底前完成首次運轉測試
2027年底能不能交出第一批 Superpower
兩項事業押同一顆核心，成功一起開路
延後一起賠掉信用